warning this video contains cold Geass
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime outpour and welcome to a
brand-new Code Geass video in this video
we will be counting down the top 5
hidden messages in the original code
geass series and we'll be looking at
whether these messages give us some
clues for what might happen in season 3
a big thank you for all the people on
our discord server for helping us out
with this video we'll be shouting some
of them out during the video but if you
would like to be a part of our discord
server and if you'd like to be part of
future discussions and theories about
code geass and other anime you can check
out our discord server the link is in
the description here at anime out or we
want to be your number one source for
all the latest news and theories for
code geass season 3 but also attack on
Titan season 2 seven deadly sin season 2
and so on so if you want to stay up to
date and be the first to know be sure to
subscribe and be sure to click that
notification bell so that you get all
the news first and without further ado
number five a quote from Dante's Inferno
if you go back to episode 21 of r2 at
exactly 11 minutes and 48 seconds right
before we enter the sword of Akasha
through the thought elevator on
communist island we see the following
message flash on screen the message
reads las siete or nice parantha void
chant rata and it is a quote in Latin by
the poet Dante ugly Arry in English this
quote means abandon all hope you who
enter here
and it is actually from Dante's Divine
Comedy the first part Dante's Inferno
canto 3 a line 9 so why does this quote
from Dante's Inferno appear at this
specific time if you look at Dante's
Divine Comedy it is made up of three
parts and the first part the one in
which this quote appears is hell in
Dante's Inferno this line actually
appears on the entrance to hell so it is
very interesting that the creators of
Code Geass chose to show us this line as
we enter the world of sea I personally
think that there is a double meaning
behind showing us this quote first from
a lucious perspective we know that he
thinks that Charles's plan to blend
all of humanity into a single
consciousness would be a terrible idea
it would stop progress it would lead to
stagnation and in many ways for Lelouch
Charles's plan would be a form of hell
on the other hand from Charles's
perspective the idea of abandoning hope
could simply mean that once there is no
more individuality and all of humanity
is blended into a single consciousness
we will no longer have any need of fear
or hope or any of those emotions because
it will always be peaceful and secure as
a single collective being at any rate I
think that the creator's decision to
show us this particularly as this
particular time is very interesting and
if you have any interpretations of why
you think they did that I'd love to hear
them in the comment and by the way did
you miss this message the first time you
saw Code Geass or did you spot it right
away let me know down below
number four Australia what is to deal
with Australia in the world of Code
Geass did you ever notice that every
time we see a world map in code geass
Australia is always left blank left in
gray so it is always portrayed as
independent of any other nation or
alliance in the world of code geass now
if Australia wasn't important and there
was no real reason to leave it separate
then the creators group easily made it a
part of the Britannian Empire or any
other Alliance so why didn't they do
that the fact that they seem to have
gone out of their way to make Australia
separate and different tells me that
Australia could be important and could
play some role in the sequel
we know that code geass takes place in
an alternative timeline so on alternate
history so we could assume that perhaps
Britannia never colonized Australia in
this world but as the Code Geass wiki
points out Australia was first
discovered by the Dutch in 1606 and the
Netherland were a separate nation from
Britannia at that time so we noticed
Australia would have been discovered in
the world of code geass and it is of
course mapped it is shown on the maps so
everyone must know that it is there in
the episode cheering mau mau implies
that australia is indeed populated we
he tells c2 that he is going to abduct
her and escape to Australia with her
while it is possible that in the world
of Code Geass Australia was simply never
colonized and that it's only inhabitants
are the native people of Australia it is
highly unlikely that Britannia and other
powerful empires throughout history will
never attempt to take over such a vast
area of land and such vast natural
resources as are found on the continent
of Australia unless there was something
there something powerful stopping them
from taking over Australia so what is
the secret of Australia are there clues
about the origins of code and Geass
hidden there do the people of Australia
possess some sort of advanced technology
or perhaps Geass related powers that
allow them to stop any other country any
other empire from colonizing them like I
mentioned earlier the fact that the
creators of Code Geass seem to have gone
out of their way to separate Australia
from the rest of the code geass world
might mean that they have something
interesting planned for Australia in the
sequel in fact I think that I discovered
something never seen before check this
out if you zoom in on Australia in the
world of koteas more more zoom and more
if you zoom in further you will see oh
you will see the anime man code geass
Australia conspiracy Illuminati
confirmed number three the ancient
civilization in this frame that flashes
by quickly in the scene where Lelouch
first makes a contract with c2 we appear
to see members of an ancient
civilization you can see that they have
the code sign on their foreheads and
their clothing looks ancient their
clothing is completely different from
clothing in the modern world of Code
Geass and it is also different from the
clothing used by the modern Geass order
in the world of Code Geass it is
established that the eighth thought
elevators the Charles uses to activate
the Ragnarok connection were actually
created by members of a mysterious
ancient civilization that was clearly
highly advanced and powerful in the new
PV which recently came out for season 3
we also appear to see shots of two
ancient temples which could be a clue
that the ancient origins of coal
and Geass and the civilization that
created the 8 tall elevators might play
an important part in the plot of season
3 I will leave it here for now but if
you want to know more about this whole
ancient civilization theory check out
our top 10 shocking theories about code
geass season 3 the link is in the
description number 2 the meaning of
Geass org is in Celtic mythology in
Irish mythology kiyose refers to a
specific obligation or prohibition that
is similar to being under a vow or a
spell if we just look at the Wikipedia
page we see that ideas can be compared
with a curse or paradoxically a gift if
someone under ideas violates the
associated taboo the in fracture will
suffer dishonor or even death on the
other hand the observing are ones chiesa
orgeat plural is believed to bring power
often it is women who plays chiesa upon
men in some cases the woman turns out to
be a goddess or other sovereignty figure
the gear is often a key device in hero
tales such as those in Irish mythology
traditionally the doom of heroes comes
about due to their violation of their
gears either by accident or by having
multiple gear sub plates on them at the
same time and having no option but to
violate 1 years in order to maintain
another so when Celtic mythology a es is
a type of contract often offered to a
man by a woman and this woman might turn
out to be a goddess or another type of
magical creature such as an immortal
which perhaps furthermore the gift
contract can be occurs if disobeyed as
was the case with MAO who couldn't bring
himself to kill c2 and fulfill their
contract and then after she abandoned
him he went insane but it could also be
a gift and lead to great power if it is
followed through if the contract is
followed through until the end this of
course has great meaning in the world of
code geass if we assume that a Lucius
contract was to fulfill C to his
original wish to die we know that he
fails to fulfill that contract and
you end result might be his death and we
know that many believed that at the end
of our to Lelouch was in fact dead but
if we assume that C 2 s original wish
changes during the course of the anime
and if we believe that her new wish is
to live happily and together with
Lelouch then the only way to Lelouch can
fulfill his contract is to actually go
on living and if you're still wondering
how the louche could have survived his
encounter with sudha whose sword at the
end of our - feel free to check out my
top three reasons Lelouch is still alive
the link is in the description and the
number one hidden message in code geass
The Tree of Life and the Rogner s if we
look at these scenes from Code Geass we
see the repeated use of imagery that
resembles a tree in this image in
particular we clearly see c2 and v2
beside what look like the roots of a
tree this imagery is reminiscent of the
several tree or the tree of life an
important mystical symbol used in the
Kabbalah of esoteric Judaism this tree
represents a map of creation and it
tells us about the nature of divinity
the nature of the human soul and the
spiritual path of ascent by man the path
of the spirits ascending to heaven and
to God in the anime Neon Genesis
Evangelion
you can see the sefirot tree used even
more blatantly as symbolism and we know
that a Mongolian influenced Code Geass
because the human instrumentality
project in Evangelion is almost the same
as Charles's ultimate goal in coal gear
so what is this symbolism trying to tell
us remember that the Tree of Life
symbolizes the spiritual ascent of man
towards God I have to thank vector
Maximus for pointing out all of this
Tree of Life symbolism in Code Geass and
after seeing as this particular comment
in one of our videos I remembered
something I remembered that in the scene
in the very first episode where Lelouch
first makes this contract we see two we
briefly see Charles in
sighs the sword of Akasha and what does
Charles say he says we will join with
the Ragnar s the legend begins again and
this is around the twenty one minute and
ten seconds in the very first episode of
code geass but who are the Ragnar is and
how will Charles join them what if the
rod Norris is the name of the ancient
civilization that created the a thought
elevators in the first place what if
these Ragnar is are no longer around
because they already activated the
Ragnarok connection once before and they
used it to ascend towards God they moved
beyond the physical form and became the
collective consciousness that we know as
God in the world of code geass we know
that this ancient civilization created
the thought elevators we know that they
created the sword of Akasha but it looks
like they also might have created the
concept of God itself in the world of
Code Geass by ascending moving beyond
physical form into a purely spiritual
pure consciousness form which we now
recognize as God in the world of Code
Geass what if what Charles is trying to
do is activate a second Ragnarok
connection in order for modern humanity
to join with the ancient Ragnar race and
become together a more robust a bigger
better collective consciousness after
all Charles would have to have known
somehow he would have had to find out
somehow about the Ragnarok connection
and what if he found ancient texts that
actually suggested that a Ragnarok
connection was already activated in the
past by this ancient civilization and he
was simply trying to recreate that
create a new world order which is why he
says the legend begins again what if
when Charles says that he wants to kill
God what he really wants is to destroy
the barrier between these ancient Rogner
s
who are the collective consciousness and
modern man and he wants to allow modern
men to join up with the Rogner s and
create a completely new God a new type
of collective consciousness what Charles
seems to want to do is to destroy the
current order which condemns modern
humans to live in the physical world
where he feels there are too many lives
too much deceit and too much suffering
and in this he reminds me of shin Hyuga
shank from a key to the exiles who
believes that life itself is a curse and
he wants to kill those he cares about in
order to save them from this curse
Charles believes that humanity would be
much happier if they joined the rod
Norris and became purely spiritual
beings the legend would then begin again
as a second Ragnarok connection allows
modern humans to ascend to a spiritual
form just like the ancient civilization
already did countless years ago if this
theory is true it would explain why a
mysterious being with cold appears in a
key to the Exile and explained that she
is a representation of pure
consciousness a purely spiritual being
she could in fact be a representation of
the rod Norris who activated the first
Ragnarok connection and ascended from
physical to purely spiritual form now
wouldn't this theory explain a lot about
the origins of the thought elevators
about why they were created in the first
place and about what happened to the
ancient civilization that created them
which no longer seems to be around
physically but could very well still be
around in spiritual forms the biggest
credit for help on this video goes to
vector Maximus but I also want to thank
Li Vladimir sickle soul maka and Lelouch
Kingsley from our discord server and
those are our top ten hidden messages in
code geass did you find any hand
messages that we didn't talk about let
me know in the comments I'd love to hear
from you be sure to subscribe and hit
the notification button for more videos
like this one and for all the latest
news and updates on code geass season 3
if you want to chat with us on a daily
basis and help come up with ideas for
new videos be sure to join our disk
court server the link is in the
description thanks so much for watching
everybody thanks for all the support and
until next time see a space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]